thank you
Provost Alan Brinkley and my good friend
Josh
for the kind words of introduction and
thank you for inviting me to participate
in the world leaders forum this year
distinguished ladies and gentlemen let
me say at the outset that it is my
distinct pleasure to address this August
audience of this prestigious university
i'm told that columbia university is the
fifth oldest institution of higher
learning in the united states and that
you are committed to preserving the
guest the quest for knowledge as more
than simply a practical pass shoot
judging from the number of reading minds
that are part of the community of
columbia university i am persuaded to
concur with one of your arm lie who said
that the best things of all human
history and thought are inside the
rectangle columbia university and so it
is need a privilege for me to address
you on the theme of the millennium
development goes from Wanda's
perspective as you know five years ago
the world's leaders met and launched the
Millennium Development Goals they made a
solemn pledge to work together to end
extreme poverty and hunger to promote
human dignity to achieve peace democracy
and by Metro sustainability by 2015
Oralia
this was we have found a de montreuil
conference on financing for development
in March 2002 and at the johannesburg
world summit on sustainable development
in September 2002 and in 2004 you our
very own professor Jeffrey Sachs led a
global team that rollout a practical a
practical plan to achieve the goals at
the time of the millennium summit the
targets for the millennium development
goals were judged to be attainable given
the amount of Worth and global abundance
as well as what Professor Sachs as
Deborah referred to as the greatest
technological and scientific explosion
of knowledge and yet despite this
unprecedented creation of worth and
knowledge there are still frightening
levels of poverty for the majority of
the world's populations and many in the
developing world continue to die over
the progression hunger malnutrition
preventable diseases and endless
conflicts it is in my view unacceptable
that today according to UN statistics
345 million sub-saharan Africans live in
poverty in some sub-saharan African
countries as many as seventy percent of
the region's population leave
unless than one dollar a day 228 million
sub-saharan Africans suffer from
undernourishment and 4.7 million
children die each year of hunger disease
that is an average of nearly 13,000
every day of 500 children dying every
hour similarly 280 million people in
sub-sahara Africa I will no access to
clean and safe drinking water and 167
million live in Islam conditions now
these statistics say it all we need no
father statistics trust that this rate
Africa is not exactly on track to meet
the millennium development goals in fact
in some targets like poverty GDP per
capita and undernourishment there will
be a regression in the situation between
now and 15 and 2015 if left to business
as usual some have of course a dude that
there is no one else to blame and I
agree that we Africans must take first
responsibility for this sorry state of
affairs on our continent but that's not
to deny the fact that in this
increasingly shrinking world
a global village as it has been referred
to all nations are interdependent
whether they are big or small rich or
poor and also
but a world where the majority live in
such a solid state or less than one
dollar day amidst the highest recorded
global productivity and concentration of
worth is an unsafe world in fact such a
world is dangerously prone to
manipulations by those whose interest in
violence international terrorism and
genocide preys on the hopelessness of
the deprived equally we must acknowledge
that this interdependence engenders
shared responsibilities and obligations
which undoubtedly include the imperative
for development and attainment of
Millennium Development words we must
collectively agree the development is
liberation from one and from fear so
that our peoples can live dignified
lives all peoples not some but judging
from the status of play in sub-sahara
Africa as I have just outlined the
picture is not promising unless we
devise together with our development
partners and agree to faithfully
implement innovative and practical
measures that can reverse the current
trends
in Rwanda we recognize the importance of
the millennium development goes and you
see them as prerequisites and the road
map for the realization of our own
vision up 2020 the blueprint for our
social economic development besides
targets the embedded besides the targets
are embedded in our poverty reduction
strategy a program of economic growth in
place since 2000 that aims to generate
worth and increase choices for the poor
so clearly we are determined to do our
bit and although there are still bought
Phoenix we seem to be making significant
progress for instance in bore number two
we have introduced universal primary
education and as a result we have
attained over have obtained over ninety
percent primary one enrollment and net
enrolment in primary schools of
eighty-two percent we have striven to
promote gender equality in all sectors
of Rwandan life and you have attained
the 50-50 rush of enrollment of girls
and both and of girls and boy child in
primary education
contained in a millennium development
goal number three as for gender equality
in decision-making organs we now have a
ratio of forty-nine percent women in
parliament and thirty-five percent in a
cabinet we are I think to a great extent
entre in the areas of gender parity and
universal primary education that said I
wish I could be as optimistic for the
other goals we are doing our best but
like other African countries there is no
way we can achieve the Millennium
Development goes without a true
partnership at the local national and
between the world and developing
countries based on a shared commitment
and determination to promote economic
and social advancement of all peoples
this will necessitate on the part of our
development partners three cardinal
things in development financing first
improvement in the quality and quantity
of official development assistance oda
second fair trade and third
debt cancellation which several
countries in Africa including Rhonda are
now benefiting from the quality of
official development assistance should
be improved by adopting needs based
approaches providing more budget support
supporting and harmonizing with the
national poverty reduction programs
reducing West and overheads and by
channeling aid to sectors that enhance
productive capacities rather than those
that perpetuate dependence there should
also be greater consultation
coordination harmonization and policy
coherence among official development
assistance recipients and donors
effective official development
assistance should be untied to
procurement of overpriced equipment and
consultants Pro Madonna countries all
these proposals are contained in both
the mantra consensus as well as the
Paris declaration on aid effectiveness
which must be implemented distinguished
audience the global commitment to
achieve the Millennium Development was
in the next ten years requires massive
mobilization of financial resources and
their immediate deployment for immediate
employment we welcome the decision by
some developed countries to
substantially increase their volume of
official development assistance
over the last few years we also
congratulate those states that have
reached or exceed the international
agreed 0.7 percent of gni for official
development assistance target and
welcomed the decision by those states
that have set timetables to achieve or
exceed that staggered by they are 2015
these commitments should significantly
improve the prospects of many developing
countries to attain the Millennium
Development Goals but for these
resources to be effective in the
attainment of the Millennium Development
Goals their disbursement should be
accelerated flexible and predictably
available for implementation fair trade
with Intel committing ourselves both in
principle practice to an open rule best
non-discriminatory and equitable
multilateral trading system any progress
that developing countries like Rwanda
might achieve in attaining the
Millennium Development Goals will not be
sustainable unless measures are chicken
at the same time to provide a great
opportunity to access the richer markets
of the developed world and thereby
increase household our national incomes
in this regard we welcome and support
the proposal for duty-free and kota free
market access
for our exports from least developed
countries to the markets of developed
countries as well as the proposal to
ease supply side constraints on the
commodity price shocks in this developed
countries to enable them take the
fullest possible advantage of increased
market access our eyes set on the
successful completion of the WTO Doha
round of multilateral trade negotiations
in 2006 and implementation of the loja
development agenda paying due regard to
agricultural trade issues realization of
trading services and the promotion of
export competitiveness the recent
decision to cancel the date of 18 highly
indebted least developed African
countries is a very commendable
manifestation of the commitment by those
countries developed to the development
of least developed countries Rwanda is
one of the 18 countries that qualified
for debt cancellation for our date once
our date once stood at US dollars 1.2
billion who's a new servicing at the
time was five hundred and twenty three
percent of exports panics cancellation
of our debt means that the government
can now genre nearly 40 million u.s.
dollars
which is previously spent annually on
debt servicing towards improving or
expanding social service delivery around
the country the challenge now is to
access sufficient grant based
development financing that will prevent
the Vasa of our debt sustainability
while providing the needed investment
for economic growth and poverty
reduction ladies and gentlemen it is
clear to us that attainment of
millennium development was is also
contingent on a good political and
economic governance in Rwanda we have
implemented several political and
economic reforms over the last decade
including democratization and
decentralization of the central and
local governments we have put in place
institutions that promote accountability
and transparency and you have introduced
measures that combat corruption and
abuse of public office we have also
implemented the service a series of
measures to ensure fiscal discipline to
eliminate West in the public sector
while also boosting thread and inward
investment we will continue to do what
checks in this process particularly in
the area of good political economic and
corporate governance may I add the trial
with you improvements in governance as a
continent and a dynamic process rather
than a static and gore we believe that
we have made significant progress which
gives us the reason to be optimistic
that will enhance the support of our
development partners we could attain the
Millennium Development Goals targets by
they are 2015 distinguished ladies and
gentlemen let me conclude by reiterating
that the socio-economic development of
our countries and the emancipation of
our people is primarily our
responsibility but a millennium
development was our a compound between
rich and poor and rich countries must
honor their commitments and fulfill the
obligations that accompany these
commitments I'm pleased to assure you
that for Wanda the will and the
enthusiasm for achieving the mdgs is
there what remains to be seen is the
same commitment on the part of our
development partners we believe that you
cannot afford to miss this opportunity
that has the potential to change the
welfare of so many in the world but
while we differ and the pre-market
children continue
to die of starvation and preventable
diseases others go to bed and fail to
sleep because they are hungry this is
not the kind of world we want to be with
the generations to come in this new
millennium I wish to say thank you for
your kind attention and i will
appreciate your questions and comments
thank you very much